of course as we continue to work
together we must also negotiate the UK
successful exit from the European Union
this will take time and it will require
serious and detailed work but as long as
we are a member of the EU we will
respect the rights and obligations of
membership I want to work with
Chancellor Merkel and my colleagues
around the European Council in a
constructive spirit to make this a
sensible and orderly departure all of us
will need time to prepare for these
negotiations and the United Kingdom will
not invoke Article 50 until our
objectives are clear and that's why have
said already this will not happen before
the end of this year I understand this
time schoo will not please everyone but
I think it is important to provide
clarity on that now we should strive for
a solution which respects the decision
of British voters but also respects the
interests of our European partners
together we should maximize the
opportunities for both the UK and the EU
and to conclude I said recently that the
United Kingdom should not be defined
exclusively by the process of our
withdrawal from the EU nor should it
define our relationships with countries
around the world of course there are
challenges ahead and much to be worked
through but I do believe that upon
leaving the European Union the United
Kingdom can forge strong and successful
relationships with European countries
and that those relationships can benefit
not just Britain but our partners too
and as we embark on that new chapter I
look forward to working with you
Chancellor to develop that successful
partnership